i'm deputy speaker presents us with a
renewed challenge
here in britain and around the world and
our strategy throughout
has been to suppress the virus until a
vaccine can make us safe
and while collectively our efforts were
working
on the old variant when faced with a new
variant that's between 50 to 70 percent
more transmissible
there's been no choice but to respond
and i understand that these regulations
that we debate today have serious
consequences
and i regret the huge costs that they
bring
but i know just as surely that these
costs are by far outweighed
by the cost that we would bear without
action and the goal is as
my right on friend said that by the
middle of next month
we plan to have offered the first dose
to everyone in the top four priority
groups
and they currently account for four out
of
five covered fatalities
and i'm not sure this is a point that
has fully been addressed which is that
because of the strong correlation
between age and
fatality from covid sadly it means that
we will be able to vaccinate
those who account those groups that
account for four out of every five
fatalities
uh within the top four uh cohorts now it
does then take two to three weeks
from the first dose to reach uh immunity
but the vaccine therefore is the way out
of this pandemic
and it's the way to a better year ahead
what's a rate limiting factor is the
amount of the actual
juice available the actual vaccine which
is not
manufactured like a chemical it is
effectively
um it is a biological product it's a bit
like if you bake your own bread madame
definitely speak i don't know if you do
but um i sometimes do um and it is a bit
like the creation of
and growth of yeast that's probably i
mean
it's probably the best way to think of
it it is a complicated and difficult
uh and difficult task and it is
um and that is the rate limiting factor
and i pay tribute to those who are
engaged in the manufacturing process of
this critical
product yes of course